des responsabilités en la matière pour
demander des comptes à la firme alors
qu'en vérité ils font encore une fois
exactement le contraire aide ces firmes
les accompagnent et ils font en sorte
que les salariés en france perdent leur
emploi dans des conditions de plus en
plus misérables tous merci beaucoup m
j'adorais la de nous avoir parlé de
votre carrière votre parcours auprès des
ouvriers que vous soutenez dans
différents plans sociaux je vous
remercie de votre fidélité vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
rt france point tv à bientôt sur rt
france
[Musique]
si demain un conflit ouvert ce produit
entre la chine et les usa
on peut penser il se déroulera dans la
mer de chine du sud
car cette zone est totalement
stratégique pour les deux buts
en 2019 la chine a construit en une
année temps de paix plus de bâtiments
que les états unis en quatre en guerre
de 1941 à 1940 en affichant ainsi sa
souveraineté en mer de chine du sud
pékin fait prévaloir des droits dits
historiques sur les règles
internationales
quand une puissance dominante constate
qu'elle est en train de se faire
dépasser par une puissance émergente la
tentation normale et de la détruire au
plan politique ou militaire avant
qu'elle n'arrive à ses fins
[Musique]
allez une en allemagne des résultats à
prendre avec des pincettes selon des
sondages sortie des urnes des
conservateurs d'angela merkel serait
nettement en tête lors des élections
régionales en saxe-anhalt
en embuscade le parti nationaliste et
menace pour le parti de la chancelière
allemande un scrutin test à trois mois
des législatives
les péruviens vote en ce moment pour
élire leur président second tour de la
présidentielle au pérou le vote est
obligatoire à la fiche deux extrêmes la
candidate de droite populiste keiko
fujimori est le représentant de gauche
radicale mais draw castillo l'enjeu
mettre fin à l'instabilité politique
au burkina faso le bilan du massacre
dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi s'est
alourdi à 160 morts dont une vingtaine
d'enfants une attaque dans la région
sensible à des trois frontières dans le
nord est du pays la plus meurtrière
depuis à 2015 elle intervient après la
suspension par la france de l'opération
barkan
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france
en allemagne le parti nationaliste asd
pourrait finalement ne pas créer la
surprise lors des régionales en
saxe-anhalt
selon les sondages sorties des urnes la
cds où le parti de la chancelière
allemande serait largement en tête
une tendance à prendre avec des
pincettes dans l'attenté des résultats
officiels aient les chrétiens démocrates
craignent est un vote sanction à trois
mois des législatives on voit cela avec
l âme et jet c'est un duel serré qui
s'annonce en saxe anhalt d'un côté
reiner haseloff le ministre président de
l'union chrétienne démocrate sortant il
dirige le land depuis 2016 à la tête
d'une coalition avec le spd et les verts
de l'autre
l'afd l'alternative pour l'allemagne
portée par oliver kirchner un parti
nationaliste et anti immigration qui
pourrait créer la surprise dans l'état
en juin notre pays nous appartient et il
doit nous appartenir à nouveau
complètement chers amis je veux que tous
et je le répète tous les demandeurs
d'asile avec des habits d'expulsion soit
expulsé maintenant et sans délai un
discours anti migrants mais pas
seulement car l'afd veut aussi puiser
dans un nouveau vivier d'électeurs celui
des opposants la politique anti kovy
d'angela merkel la formation vise le
rang de leader régional ce qui serait
une première nationale
même si la fd devenait le parti le plus
fort c'est qu'il ne semble pas être le
cas pour le moment seul aurait également
un impact limité sur l'ambiance générale
dans le pays
cela dépendra simplement de la façon
dont une au cd ou c est son traître à ce
résultat dans son ensemble et si un
débat sera alors lancée sur
l'opportunité de former une coalition
avec la f10 décision qui serait
extrêmement dommageable pour la céder ou
fédéral
pour l'heure le ministre-président cd ou
de saxe-anhalt exclu toute alliance avec
l'alternative pour l'allemagne mais les
troupes de reiner haseloff sont divisés
sur la question et un courant se dessine
en faveur d'une coalition avec life des
plus généralement et d'après les
derniers sondages près d'un électeur sur
quatre est hanté par la droite radicale
dans ce scrutin
en attendant une victoire de l'efs des
serait un sérieux revers pour les
chrétiens démocrates qui tiennent la
saxe-anhalt depuis 19 ans ce serait
aussi un très mauvais présage pour son
chef fédéral
armin laschet tu as moins de quatre mois
des élections législatives
des élections qui doivent acter la fin
de l'ère angela merkel après 16 ans à la
tête de l'allemagne
et on va écouter quelques réactions
recueillies à la sortie à des bureaux de
vote en vue d'associer j'espère qu'il y
aura des améliorations pour l'avenir
surtout de la part du parti pour lequel
je veux voter
dernièrement il y a eu beaucoup de
discussions et mon plus grand souhait
est que l'afd n'obtiennent pas autant de
voix qu'avant car c'est très
réactionnaire ce qu'ils les montrent
chaque premièrement nous souhaitons que
30 ans après la réunification de
l'allemagne
nos retraites soient traités de la même
manière qu en allemagne de l'ouest et
que nous puissions gagner un salaire
régulier car aujourd'hui encore nous
gagnons mois en allemagne de l'est est
les péruviens un vote pour élire leur
président un second tour de la
présidentielle qui oppose la candidate
de la droite populiste keiko fujimori à
pedro castillo de la gauche radicale un
scrutin sur fond de pandémie
le pérou est le cinquième pays le plus
endeuillé au monde on voit cela avait
créé coin dos et qui de pedro castillo
de keiko fujimori succédera aux
centristes francisco saga ch'ti à la
tête du pérou
c'est ce dimanche que les électeurs
choisissent dans un pays où le vote est
obligatoire sous peine de se voir
infliger une amende d'une vingtaine de
dollars
les options qui s'offrent à eux
représentent deux extrêmes tout d'abord
la gauche radicale avec l'instituteur
pedro castillo reconnaissable à son
crayon et son chapeau parmi les points
clés de son programme mettre en avant
l'industrie locale et entreprendre une
politique de nationalisations
c'est un professeur de la rue un
professeur de quartier il me donne de
l'espoir
castillon représente une réponse aux
politiques et structures obsolètes qui
se sont développées au cours des
différents gouvernements qui ont dirigé
le pays
c'est un pays qui a été sous plusieurs
aspects assez fermé à la connaissance on
le voit en analysant l'histoire de
l'éducation
face à lui la candidate de la droite
populiste keiko fujimori fille de
l'autoritaire alberto fujimori président
dans les années 90 est actuellement sous
les barreaux pour corruption et crime
contre l'humanité dans le volet justice
elle même risque 30 ans de prison dans
le cadre d'un scandale de corruption lié
à une importante entreprise brésilienne
de btp en cas d'élection elle
deviendrait la première femme présidente
du pérou fujimori promet une politique
libérale pour contrer un étatisme qui
selon elle mènerait l'économie
péruvienne à sa perte
je sais qu'elle va nous protéger nous
aider au ministère de la santé et des
tous les habitants du pérou elle va nous
faire avancer car ce dont le pérou a
besoin c'est d'une femme entreprenante
pas d'un crillon qui ne fait que des
bêtises
je suis ici parce que je dois défendre
le pérou contre le communisme
le modèle que pedro castillo préconisé
vraiment un modèle qui a déjà échoué au
pérou dans les années 80 et que fujimori
a enterré en faisant de la banque
centrale de réserve du pérou une
institution totalement autonome elle les
deux candidats se rejoignent toutefois
sur certains points sociétaux comme
celui de l'avortement auquel tous deux
sont opposés dans l'un des pays les plus
endeuillé au monde par la pandémie
l'aspect sanitaire pourrait aussi faire
pencher la balance les dernières
enquêtes d'opinion donnent un léger
avantage à pedro castillo est l'un des
enjeux de l'élection tourner une page
d'instabilité politique dans un pays
marqué par de nombreuses institutions
deux chefs d'état depuis elle les années
2000 la dernière en date celle du
président martin giscard en 2020 a les
détails c'est en images
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
le bilan de l'attaqué meurtrière dans la
nuit de vendredi à samedi au burkina
faso s'est alourdi au moins 160 morts
selon des sources locales citées par l'
agence france-presse
un deuil national de trois jours a été
décrété jusqu'à demain soir
elle est victime toutes civiles dont une
vingtaine d'enfants
le drama est survenu à solane dans le
nord-est du pays la région à des trois
frontières avec le mali et le niger à
des hommes armés ont d'abord visé un
poste de supplétifs de l'armée puis des
maisons de villageois dans la capitale
ouagadougou
c'est le choc écoutez sa réaction on a
vraiment déployer dès la situation voilà
vraiment ça nous ferons appel maintenant
on a peur voilà mon appel jean et si on
incapacité des glissements capable
d'attaquer
l'attaqué est celui d'un village
il n'y a pas eu de réaction après pour
compenser
il faut baisser 1705 village a vraiment
ça n'a pas été bon j'ai pas été content
et de l'association ça avait pris quoi
ca avait un temps s'arrêter à la voyais
que l'on pensait même si tu es bon ça va
et maintenant ces situations grâce à des
prix les outils les enceintes ou en ski
c'est qu'on a entendu ses nouvelles
après maints ça pousse en tant que
burkinabè quoi ça nous fait mal ça nous
fait mal reçue par canton
le super content faut que les autorités
veulent voir prendre peut aider la
population surtout dans les villages au
nord
la valaisanne souffre beaucoup voilà
donc on demande le président du faso n'a
pas aidé les as du nord parce qu'on va
le faire pour le roi parce que au moins
100 morts
c'est pas facile d'accuser journée
tellement mal
il s'agit de l'attaqué la plus
meurtrière depuis à 2015 dans le pays et
cela alors que la france a annoncé cette
semaine suspendre ses opérations
militaires conjointes avec les forces
maliennes le burkina faso a fait face
ces dernières années un regain d'actes
terroristes les précisions avec yamina
benguigui
au moins 1400 morts en l'espace de cinq
ans c'est le bilan des attaques
terroristes au burkina faso des attaques
violentes et récurrentes située entre le
mali et le niger
deux pays du sahel soumis eux aussi à de
nombreuses attaques terroristes
le burkina faso est en proie à de
multiples attentats meurtriers depuis
des décennies le terroriste algérien
mokhtar belmokhtar affiliés à al qaïda
au maghreb islamique est connu pour être
le cerveau de plusieurs attaques
meurtrières dans toute la région
sahélienne il s'attribue notamment
l'attentât du 15 janvier 2016 contre
l'hôtel splendid et le restaurant
cappuccino à ouagadougou
trente personnes majoritairement des
occidentaux sont tués en 2018 des
attaques simultanées vise l'état major
des armées burkinabè et l'ambassade de
france
si les militaires ont succombé aux
violences et 85 personnes ont été
blessées l'attentât est cette fois
revendiqué par le groupe de soutien à
l'islam et aux musulmans liés à al qaïda
le 6 novembre 2019 c'est un convoi
transportant des employés de la mine
d'or de bongo exploitée par une société
canadienne qui est attaqué au total 38
personnes y laisseront la vie le 19 août
2010 9 24 soldats sont tués dans
l'attaqué d'une base militaire à
koudougou à la frontière malienne
l'année 2000 21 avaient déjà été
marquées par des violences
il y à un peu plus d'un mois on
apprenait la mort de deux journalistes
espagnols et le patron irlandais d'une
ong exécuté alors qu'il se trouvait avec
une patrouille anti braconnage les
attaques dites dia dit ce ne sont pas
les seuls a ensanglanté le pays
les conflits intercommunautaires
opposant parfois les tribus parfois les
religions sont aussi une source de
motivation à l'origine d'un grand nombre
d' attaques meurtrières au burkina faso
le conflit qui oppose une tribu people
locaux guyot go groupes d'autodéfense
paysans en est un exemple
en algérie le mouvement du irak
s'intensifient à l'approché de
législatives et à paris place de la
république plusieurs collectifs se sont
rassemblés en soutien au mouvement
algérien ont fait le point avec notre
reporter estelle fâchent sur place
la diaspora algérienne se mobilisent ici
place de la république dès manifestons
proulx irak ils se rassemblent en
soutien à ce mouvement de contestation
populaire née en février 2019 en algérie
et qui avait précipité la démission du
président bouteflika deux mois plus tard
le 12 juin prochain là-bas des élections
législatives anticipées sont organisées
des élections considérées comme une
mascarade pour ces manifestants je
propose de les écouter
la première revendiquée revendications
du peuple algérien aujourd'hui sirat si
ledit mentalement de la junte militaire
nous ne pouvons pas organiser des
élections libres sont le démantèlement
de rage depuis les terres en même temps
il ya là la police politique la
dissolution de la police politique
c'est une exigence de la révolution nous
ne pouvons pas faire de la politique
nous ne pouvons pas accéder à notre
citoyenneté sont le démantèlement et à
la dissolution de la police politique
on ne peut pas dire qu'il y à un climat
serein pour faire des élections
législatives donc un débat démocratique
émergence des idées concurrence les
idées et ses comptes ya plus de deux
cents 200 personnes en prison ça il faut
le il faut le dire ce contexte n'est pas
du tout un contexte de deux camps on
dire de compétition démocratique
c'est un pouvoir dictatorial illégitime
il a toujours opéré par les coups d'état
ou les fraudes électorales
donc nous on va pas
encore pourquoi aller participer à ce
pseudo jeu pluraliste qui a été
déclenchée depuis 89 88
on a vu que la finit par la mine et la
classe politique démocratique plus
largement vous l'aurez compris la
diaspora algérienne réclame ici je cite
une transition démocratique indépendante
du pouvoir en place est la consécration
dans l'état de droit et de citoyenneté
ils réclament aussi la libération des
prisonniers politiques
sachez que plus de 200 personnes sont
actuellement incarcérés en algérie pour
des faits en lien avec le irak selon des
organisations de défense des droits de
l'homme alors ici vous allez le voir sur
ces images de didier mulot des prises de
parole sont organisées initialement une
marche en direction de la place de la
bastille était prévu mais selon les
organisateurs elle aurait été interdite
par la préfecture de police de paris ce
sera donc un rassemblement states et qui
si cet après midi six autres
manifestations également à paris de
nombreuses personnes se sont rassemblées
place de la république pour la paix en
afghanistan
un appel de l'association enfants
d'afghanistan et d'ailleurs qui demande
à l'europe d'agir écouter son président
on sait très bien qu'on va retourner
dans les années 90 et que in der est
inévitable mais par contre si l'europe
intervienne politiquement si l'europe
pour entrer dans les négociations avec
les américains et aussi avec les
talibans et les autres
membre de 2,2 le temps on est sûr qu au
moins on aura une autre parce que on
connaît l'europe on est on est en train
de sonner dans le pays de droits de
l'homme
c'est pourquoi je demande que le
président français interviennent dans
les négociations on ne demande pas du
tout dudley de militaires ou de savoir
si aux militaires dans le monde rentrait
dans les négociations on en vient à la
situation épidémique en france à
quelques jours d'une étape du
déconfinement le 9 juin les indicateurs
sont toujours à la baisse mais attention
plusieurs cas du variant indien appelée
delta ont été détectés une trentaine
dans les landes et on suspecte des
dizaines d'autres les investigations
sont toujours en cours les autorités
appellent tu es la plus grande vigilance
face à la souche jugé plus contagieuse
elle mise à fond sur la vaccination qui
avance bien mais la défiance envers
astrazeneca persiste résultat les stocks
s'accumulent les précisions c'est avec
monaco dès lors le vaccin d'astrazeneca
n'inspire décidément pas confiance aux
français et les doses ont beaucoup de
mal à s'écouler
aujourd'hui il est utilisé à 60% contre
90% pour le freezer ou le modern art en
échec dû aux nombreuses polémiques
autour de son efficacité de ces effets
secondaires ainsi qu'à sa suspension
dans plusieurs pays européens
de quoi dissuader une bonne partie de la
population
et pourtant la livraison de ce vaccin
continuent d'affluer la france attend
près de 4,5 millions de doses
d'astrazeneca d'ici fin juin
mais alors que faire de toutes ces doses
une fois livré ses vaccins deviennent la
propriété des états mais l'union
européenne n'est jamais bien loin pour
surveiller la destination des stocks et
pour éviter toute perte la solution
serait et que les doses excédentaires
soient donnés ou revendus à des pays
tiers
l'europe a déjà décidé à qui elle allait
donner les doses boudé par ses
concitoyens aux pays les plus pauvres
notamment en afrique
nombre de doses ont d'ailleurs déjà été
données au programme kovacs kovacs et un
système mis en place par l'om est pour
que les pays les plus riches participent
à la distribution des vaccins aux pays
pauvres à ce jour 72 millions de doses
ont été livrées dans 126 pays via ce
dispositif
en avril la france avait elle même donné
quelques cent mille doses d'astrazeneca
aux pays africains
mais malgré l'élan de générosité des
européens et l'urgence de la situation
les pays africains aussi ne semblent pas
tous convaincus de l'efficacité du
vaccin en effet pourquoi envoyer de
l'astra zeneca pour soigner des
populations africaines plutôt jeunes
alors qu'en europe ce même vaccin est
déconseillé au moins de 55 ans la
république démocratique du congo par
exemple a reçu en mars dernier 1,7
million de doses d'astrazeneca
mais le pays a retardé le début de sa
campagne suite aux doutes sur ses effets
secondaires qui émergeait en europe
le soudan du sud lui a dû renvoyer 72
mille doses du même vaccin à cause des
réticences de sa population
idem pour le malawi qui a dû détruire
seize mille doses d'astrazeneca dont la
date de péremption était dépassée
l'autre solution c'est la revente elle
permettrait de limiter les pertes
financières et de négocier des tarifs
plus bas
reste à savoir qui serait preneur des
doses d'astrazeneca
alors que l'union européenne qui n'a pas
renouvelé ses commandes
astrazeneca fait don de ces doses à
l'afrique un laboratoire s'affirme déjà
comme le grand gagnant de ce désamour
céphise heures qui vient de signer avec
bruxelles
un troisième contrat pour l'achat d'un
virgule 8 milliards de doses la
vaccination des mineurs en france les 12
8 ans pourront se faire vacciner à
partir du 15 juin en belgique ce sera le
cas pour les 16 17 ans à partir de
juillet et la belgique qui poursuit son
déconfinement progressive dès mercredi
la réouverture des salles de restaurant
est les précisions de maxime a bola
alors qu'elle vient de passer la barre
des 25 mille morts liés aux coville 19
la belgique passe la vitesse supérieure
dès mercredi bruxelles poursuit son plan
de déconfinement pour cet été un mois
après la réouverture des terrasses les
restaurants vont pouvoir accueillir des
clients en salle entre 8 heures et 22
heures avec un maximum de quatre
personnes par table de nombreuses
activités intérieurs vont elles aussi
pouvoir reprendre une étape importante
rendue possible par la nette décrue des
cas 2 qu'ovide et l'accélération de la
vaccination
nous voyons une très forte baisse des
deux nombre des personnes qui se
trouvent dans les soins intensifs les
chiffres les plus récents montrent
qu'aujourd'hui il ya trois cent quarante
et une personnes dans nos centres de
soins intensifs plus de 4.8 millions de
belges ses 53 % de la population adulte
a déjà reçu minimum une première dose de
vaccination la vaccination qui joue un
rôle central dans ce plan de
déconfinement notamment pour les
déplacements comme c'est le cas
actuellement les voyageurs revenant de
zone verte ou orange ne seront pas
soumis à une quarantaine et dès le 1er
juillet ce ne sera plus le cas pour ceux
en provenance d'une zone rouge
à condition de présenter un certificat
qu'ovide attestant d'être totalement
vaccinés ou de justifier d'un test pcr
négatif de -2 72 heures ou encore
d'apporter la preuve que l'on a guéri du
coc vide 19 après la population adultes
et seniors bruxelles passe à la
vaccination des mineurs à partir du mois
prochain les jeunes de 16 17 ans
pourront recevoir leur première
injection de file review ntech la
vaccination de cette tranche d'âge sera
réalisée dans la foulée de celle des
jeunes de 18 ans à partir du mois de
juillet
ils commenceront à recevoir une
invitation concernant la première dose
mais contrairement à la france qui va
plus loin en ouvrant la vaccination aux
12-18 ans le 15 juin prochain
la belgique c'est montre plus prudente
la vaccination des enfants de moins de
16 ans n'est pas encore envisagée des
analyses scientifiques et éthiques
complémentaires sont nécessaires à cette
fin
à ce jour plus d'un belge sur cinq est
totalement vacciner contre le gobie 19
l'élargissement de la vaccination anti
coded en belgique dont se félicite
gilbert baignade y est président de
l'association belge à des syndicats
médicaux propose de l'écouter
aujourd'hui en belgique aux mains un peu
plus de 40% de la population totale
il ya eu sa première lourde une
vingtaine de pourcents qui a vu ses deux
doses évidemment les très bonnes pour
les personnes à risque comme on dit
puisqu'on a dépassé les 80% on est à 80
3% et qu'elle est très bonne pour des
personnes âgées
donc on est à un bon 60% pour les
personnes de plus de 65 ans ce sont des
bons chiffres mais vous voyez bien au
niveau de la population totale
ce n'est pas assez élevé donc vacciner
les plus jeunes pas améliorée ouverture
et la section labo l'ensemble de la
société
les israéliens attendent les votes de
confiance du parlement après l'annoncé
cette semaine d'un nouveau gouvernement
formé par ailleurs lapider ce sera
peut-être dans le courant des sept
prochains jours
ainsi le nouveau cabinet valider ce sera
la fin du règne de benyamin nétanyahou
ont fait le point avec françois xavier
lambert il aura tout fait pour
s'accrocher à son poste après douze ans
de pouvoir en continu
benyamin nétanyahou devrait selon toute
vraisemblance quitter son poste de
premier ministre dans quelques jours
tout s'est joué mercredi soir quelques
heures après l'élection du nouveau
président israélien le travailliste
issacar dogues tard dans la soirée le
centriste yaïr lapid annonce une
nouvelle coalition réunissant les 61
députés nécessaires
une alliance hétéroclite faite de
parties très opposées sur le plan
politique deux partis de gauche deux
centristes et trois de droite et surtout
le parti arabe israélien je viens de
signer un accord avec l'aiea et rapide
pour qu'il puisse déclarer qu'il peut
former un gouvernement après que nous
soyons parvenus à un nombre important
d'accord sur différents sujets qui
servent les intérêts de la société arabe
et apporte des solutions aux problèmes
urgents des arabes dans plusieurs
domaines
c'est la première fois depuis 1992 quand
partis arabes israéliens soutient
gouvernement une annonce d'autant plus
surprenante que la coalition comprend
des membres de la droite radicale
notamment des députés issus du parti de
naftali bennett ancien ministre de la
défense de benyamin nétanyahou pour
intégrer cette coalition
il aurait obtenu une garantie celle d'un
partage du pouvoir avec les ir lapide
chacun des deux hommes devant dirigé le
gouvernement pendant deux ans loin de
ces tractations politiciennes
de nombreux israéliens n'ont pas attendu
pour célébrer ce nouveau gouvernement
[Musique]
nous sommes si heureux qu'après ces deux
années épuisante nous ayons enfin un
gouvernement
nous avions presque perdu espoir et nous
espérons qu'après ces deux années très
difficiles nous aurons enfin une
nouvelle ère incroyable qui ramènera
enfin l'espoir en israël nous avons
réussi à renverser ce gouvernement
tyrannique et illicites
nous espérons le meilleur rien n'est
certain mais la volonté du peuple
vaincra c'est un moment historique
après quatre ans de lutte nous avons
réussi à renverser le gouvernement
maléfique des netanyahu
si cette coalition est investi benyamin
nétanyahou quittera son poste de premier
ministre après 25 ans de pouvoir au
total son premier mandat remontant à la
fin des années 90 mais le chef du
gouvernement et ses partisans ne s'avoue
pas encore vaincu pour inverser la
tendance
il leur faudrait convaincre certains
députés rallier à la pid notamment ceux
issus du parti de bennett benyamin
nétanyahou pourrait aussi jouer sur les
divisions entre ces partis que presque
tout oppose de la position vis-à-vis du
conflit palestinien à la relance de
l'économie
les israéliens devraient en tous les cas
être rapidement fixé le vote de
confiance pourrait avoir lieu mercredi
prochain ou lundi 14 juin
et c'est la femme ce journal merci à
vous à 2 l'avoir suivi on va se
retrouver en direct dans 30 minutes
rester avec nous sur air france
et
[Musique]
pour beaucoup le foot a été synonyme
d'évasion durant cette période de la
pandémie
quel est le rôle justement du football
dans notre société en temps de crise je
pense ça a été bien de continuer le
football pour